recognize your two barriers the two
biggest barriers to good decision-making
are your ego and your blind spots
together they make it very difficult for
you to objectively see what's true about
you and your circumstances and to make
the best possible decisions by getting
the most out of others if you can
understand how the machine that is the
human brain works you can understand why
these barriers exist and how to adjust
your behavior to make yourself happier
more effective and better at interacting
with others a understand your ego
barrier when I refer to your ego barrier
I'm referring to the subliminal defense
mechanisms that make it hard for you to
accept your mistakes and weaknesses your
deepest seeded needs and fears such as
your need to be loved and the fear of
losing love the need to survive and the
fear of not surviving the need to be
important and the fear of not mattering
reside in primitive parts of your brain
such as the amygdala which are
structures in your temporal lobe that
process emotions because these areas of
your brain are not accessible to your
conscious awareness it is virtually
impossible for you to understand what
they want and how they control you they
oversimplify things and react
instinctively they crave praise and
respond to criticism as an attack even
when the higher-level parts of the brain
understand that constructive criticism
is good for you
they make you defensive especially when
it comes to the subject of how good you
are at the same time higher level
consciousness resides in your neocortex
more specifically in the part called the
prefrontal cortex this is the most
distinctively human feature of your
brain relative to the rest of the brain
it's larger in humans than in most other
species this is where you experience the
conscious awareness of decision-making
the so called executive function as well
as the
of logic and reasoning be your to use
fight to control you it's like dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde though you're higher
level you is not aware of your lower
level you this conflict is universal if
you pay attention you can actually see
when the different parts of a person's
brain are arguing with each other for
example when someone gets angry with
himself his prefrontal cortex is
sparring with his amygdala in other
words his upper level self is battling
with his lower level self when someone
asks why did I let myself eat all that
cake the answer is because the lower
level you won out over the thoughtful
higher level you once you understand how
your logical conscious you and your
emotional subconscious you fight with
each other you can imagine what it's
like when you're to use deal with other
people and their to them it's a mess
those lower level cells are like attack
dogs they want to fight even when
they're higher level cells want to
figure things out this is very confusing
because you and the people you are
dealing with typically don't even know
these lower level beasts exists never
mind that they're trying to hijack
everyone's behavior let's look at what
tends to happen when someone disagrees
with you and asks you to explain your
thinking because your program to view
such challenges as attacks you get angry
even though it would be more logical for
you to be interested in the other
person's perspective especially if they
are intelligent when you try to explain
your behavior sometimes your
explanations don't make any sense that's
because your lower level you is trying
to speak through your upper level you
your deep-seated hidden motivations are
in control so it's impossible for you to
logically explain what you're doing even
the most intelligent people generally
behave this
way and it's tragic to be effective you
must not let your need to be right be
more important than your need to find
out what's true if you're too proud of
what you know or how good you are at
something you will learn less make
inferior decisions and fall short of
your potential see understand your blind
spot barrier in addition to your ego
barrier you and everyone else also have
blind spots areas where your way of
thinking prevents you from seeing things
accurately just as we all have different
ranges for hearing pitch and seeing
colors we have different ranges for
seeing and understanding things we see
things in our own way for example some
people naturally see big pictures and
miss small details while others
naturally see details and miss big
pictures some are linear thinkers while
others are more lateral and so what
naturally people can't appreciate what
they can't see a person who can't
identify patterns and synthesize doesn't
know what it's like to see patterns and
synthesize any more than a colorblind
person knows what it's like to see color
these differences in how our brains work
are much less apparent than differences
in how our bodies work colorblind people
eventually find out that they're
colorblind whereas most people never see
or understand the ways in which their
ways of thinking are making them blind
to make it even harder we don't like to
see ourselves or others as having blind
spots even though we all have them when
you point out someone's psychological
weaknesses it's generally about as well
received as if you pointed out their
physical weaknesses if you're like most
people you have no clue about how other
people see things and aren't good at
seeking to understand what they're
thinking because you're too preoccupied
with telling them what you yourself
think is correct in other
you're close-minded you presume too much
this closed-mindedness is terribly
costly it causes you to miss out on all
sorts of wonderful possibilities and
dangerous threats that other people
might be showing you and it blocks
criticism that can be constructive and
even life-saving the end result of these
two barriers is that parties and
disagreements typically remain convinced
that they're right and often end up
angry at each other
this is illogical and leads the
suboptimal decision-making after all
when two people reach opposite
conclusions someone must be wrong
shouldn't you want to make sure that
that someone isn't you this failure to
benefit from other's thinking
doesn't just occur when disagreements
arise it occurs when people encounter
problems that they're trying to solve
when trying to figure things out most
people spin in their own heads instead
of taking in all the wonderful thinking
available to them as a result they
continually run toward what they see and
keep crashing into what they are blind
to until the crashing leads them to
adapt those who adapt do so by a
teaching their brains to work in a way
that doesn't come naturally for example
the creative person learns to become
organized through discipline and
practice be they use compensating
mechanisms for example programmed
reminders and Orsi they learn to rely on
the help of others who are strong where
they are weak differences in thinking
can be symbiotic and complimentary
instead of disruptive for example the
lateral approach to thinking that is
common among creative people can lead
them to be unreliable
while more linear thinkers are often
more dependable some people are more
emotional while others are more logical
and so on none of these individuals
would be able to
succeed at any kind of complex project
without having the help of others who
have complementary strengths Aristotle
defined tragedy as a terrible outcome
arising from a person's fatal flaw a
flaw then had it been fixed instead
would have led to a wonderful outcome in
my opinion these two barriers ego and
blind spots are the fatal flaws that
keep intelligent hardworking people from
living up to their potentials would you
like to learn how to get past them you
can do it everybody can here's how